Speaker 1: All right. Let's get right into
our Friday mailbag. The Friday mailbag,
I have to say, on average has been improving in
quality with occasional really horrible emails.
But you can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have something to say. Sometimes people
will ask for corrections in the Friday mailbag
if they are appropriate. I'm glad to give them
we don't hide the corrections. You know, on the
last page of the paper or anything like that,
we put them at the top of the mailbag when
appropriate. Okay, let's start. First email
is from Bob. This is kind of interesting, Bob.
Send some questions for the future and says, Hey,
David, I'm from the year 3328. I was watching
your show in the historical archives and found
that insightful. I was hoping you could give me
perspective on issues people are dealing with
today. One Do you think clone marriage should be
legal now? See, I don't even understand that. Do
you mean clones of the same person marrying each
other or just clones in general getting married?
But probably, yeah. I mean, I don't know.
They're different people. Sure. Number two,
should genetic engineering be guaranteed coverage
by health insurance? Probably. I believe by 33,
28, there at least will be insurance for that.
Three are alien species fit to serve in earth
politics if they are legal citizens? 100%, I
believe if you are a naturalized earthling,
even if you come from a different planet and
listen, if you speak the language, if you
understand our system, if you share our values.
Who do I sound like? I don't know. On aliens
from other planets being being politicians. Should
I be able to vote? I think no on that. And number
five is debris pollution from asteroid mining,
something the government should try to regulate in
the wake of the recent Mars freighter disaster?
I would say yes, sir. I think I would be very
much able to make decisions about 30 year 33, 28,
world governance. I like that, Bob, really giving
giving us something to think about there. Let's
go next to Michael writing in about Alex Jones.
Michael says, David, do you think Alex Jones
is now a suicide risk? If so, is he likely
to take others with him? I think he should be
carefully watched. When you consider his obsession
with firearms, his pathological anger and the
impossibility of ever recovering from the verdict
against him, I believe he has been backed into a
corner. His agenda has been chaos and destruction
from the beginning, and now he will take it to the
limit, I fear. I would not be surprised to hear
of his committing a mass murder suicide. I hope
there are people around him who can prevent this.
I wonder the same of Trump if DeSantis wins the
primary now. So. So there are good questions here.
I don't think Trump is liable to do self harm
if DeSantis defeats him in the primary. I don't.
I do see Alex Jones as a possible
self-harm risk. I don't get the
sense of Alex Jones necessarily
taking others down with him.
I know that many of you might be surprised and say
his rhetoric about others is really wacky. Maybe
I'm wrong. I see Alex Jones primarily physically
speaking, as a risk to himself. Next, the email
is from Alan. Alan argues In response to what
I asked last week, Are Trumpists too far gone?
Alan says Trump supporters are not too far gone.
And writes, David, Sir, you recently asked on
your show if Trump supporters are too far gone,
if they could be put in the right environment,
I say no. However, many Trump supporters only
consume TV programs that reinforce their positions
or are being funneled into extremist media in
their social media by a I TV host. And social
media companies are making tons of money off
of all this, and it will not stop without some
kind of legislation. The legislation is not coming
because these people are voting and more extreme
politicians who either have the same goals or also
profit. I have lost a friend, but she was not lost
to Trump at first. She was funneled into Q anon
by Twitter. If I ever get the motivation, I'll
send some old chat threads. They are insane. I do
agree with one aspect of this, which is I do think
a complete environmental shift for these Trumpists
would have an impact because we have a study that
says that I don't know if it was like nine months
or maybe a year or 18 months ago. We had a study
that measured the effect, what happens if you take
Trumpists or I think it was like Fox News viewers,
people who primarily or exclusively get their
news from Fox. You take them out of that and you
give them a month of something different and they
tested a few different, something different. And
their views did begin to change. But it required
getting off of the Fox News. So. I agree with
Alan. Very difficult to make that happen. Carl
wrote in with one of the many corrections about
my interview with Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell.
As I told you all, it's really hard to correct
everything when someone tells hundreds of lies
during an interview. One of the things Pillow
claimed was that all the 2020 election lawsuits
that were thrown out were thrown out for standing
and not on the merits. It turns out that's
not true. Carl wrote to me about it and said,
Please pin Mike Lindell down next time on the six
election suits issue. Most were dismissed for lack
of evidence. Not the right wing claim repeated
a trillion times that they were all dismissed
for lack of standing. This is an easy one with
court document proof. Yes. Great information. If
he's back on or if someone else tries that talking
point on me, I will be prepared. It can be really
difficult to prepare for every talking point, and
I didn't have examples, specific examples in front
of me. Bruce also wrote in about the interview
with Mike Pillow. Says, David, I'm a big fan and
I count on you to provide me the latest and most
accurate news. However, I do have some criticism
about your interview with Mike. It was unnecessary
for you to correct Mike's mispronunciations. It
made you look like you were trying to demonstrate
how much more educated you are than him. There
were far more important topics to cover,
so the only correction I made was that he
pronounced Kamala Harris's name incorrectly. And
for me, that's not about education. Right wingers
don't even respect her enough. To learn how her
name is said. I believe there is much more to the
constant mispronunciation of Kamala Harris's name
for these right wingers. Why do the left wingers?
It's not education. Why do the left wingers know
how to pronounce it and the right wingers don't?
I believe there is a xenophobic, racist component
to it. And it's a an. I mean, listen, guys,
it's when I jokingly say Tulsi Gabbard. Right.
What am I doing when I do that? We all know what
I'm doing. Okay. I'm doing it on purpose with
them. I don't know if they just don't actually
respect the person enough to know what their name
is. I know it's not Dan Bongino. It's Dan Bongino.
All right. Next email is from James. With the
Army using electric vehicles, convince right
wingers to go electric. Another left progressive
YouTuber brought up that the Department of Defense
is looking for a new light recon vehicle and
intended intend on that being an electric vehicle.
The current proposal is a militarized version of
General Motors Hummer electric vehicle. He thinks
this will be what pushes the anti electric vehicle
right into embracing EVs, because that crowd
has a strong pull towards trying to imitate the
military. I'm not so sure that the right's desire
for tactical is strong enough to wipe out wipe
out the stupid impression that EVs will somehow
emasculate them. Yeah, I agree. If the military
became known for really rugged electric vehicles.
I do believe that that would push a bunch of right
wingers to at least be open to electric vehicles.
The electric F-150 has made significant inroads.
I don't know the status of the electric Hummer,
but it sounds like that maybe that would as well.
But there is going to be it's going to be sort
of a stubborn belief that electric vehicles are
terrible and bad and feminine and all this stuff
for a while. But I think if the Army started using
EVs, it would make a difference. Chris asks a good
question. Who is they? Asks Chris. David, love
your show. Have a question. Who is they? Why is
it that the right always says they are taking
your rights? They don't want you to know they
hate America. For a group that hates pronouns,
it is odd how they lean on the mysterious they so
much in responding to legitimate questions, don't
you think? Keep up the good work. Yeah. I mean,
listen. They is a catch all for some combination
of Democrats, Marxists, socialists, communists,
locusts, antifa, BLM, sometimes Jews. If
it's inconvenient, sometimes minorities,
some, yeah. They can be anything. They can be
whatever best fits the story. So if they go,
they're holding you down. They're not letting
you live the life you want to live. Could be
anybody. And depending on whether the story is
about the U.S. government or some shadowy elite
cabal or who knows, it's just a fill in the
blank and they'll just go through it and try
try again until they get something that fits. I
now I have to say. Sometimes the word they does
come naturally once you've already made clear
who you're talking about. So sometimes I'll say.
In a story, I'll I'll open it by saying the
most religious element of the American right
wing has decided that they are going to vote on an
election and election only. And then I'll say more
stuff. And then later I'll say they. I'm referring
back to that same very most religious element of
the American right wing. I try to remind myself I
should try to restate who it is I'm talking about
to avoid falling into this the thing. So Chris's
email is a good reminder Buster wrote in about
voter fraud. I actually can't tell if this is for
real. Buster says, How could you possibly do that
long of a response video about what would convince
you that there was voter fraud and not talk about
2000 mules? The movie was cheesy with its use
of dark rooms and drama, but the evidence was
extremely compelling. 2000 mules is exactly the
voter fraud evidence you said you would accept.
I don't know if this person is for real or not.
2000 mules was a joke. We've already gone through
this multiple times. 2000 mules is based on very
specious geolocation data of mobile phones that
they have not even actually connected to voting
related activities. It is completely speculative.
It doesn't actually show anything other than
supposedly certain people with mobile phones
were grouped in different areas that they
claim are suspiciously close to ballot drop
boxes. That's all they have. I'm simplifying a
little bit. It was not compelling. It was not
compelling. And if someone thinks that 2000 meals
is proof of anything other than Dinesh D'Souza's
delusion and narcissism. Then I don't know that
we have much to talk about. We have a great bonus
show for you today. Don't miss the bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Especially in this era
of Alex Jones hating the bonus show.
Speaker 5: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Well, all right, Alex, thank you
very much. It is a great time to sign up at
join pacman dot com. Join Pacman dot com coupon
code big voting 20 to just a couple of weeks
left before the big voting day. Help your
sign up and I'll see you on the bonus shelf.